PAUL SAXMAN: Hello, and welcome
to Google Maps Garage.
I'm Paul Saxman.
And with me this week is Josh
"Raster Data" Livni.
Today we're going to talk about
getting raster data in
your mobile map using the Google
Maps Android API and
some WMS services, or raster
data services, which Josh is
going to talk about.
But what we mean about getting
raster data in your map is, if
we look at the tablet
here, this is the
Azavea Philly tree map.
And you can see here, as we
zoom in, this application
actually has a lot
of data in it.
These are actually individual
trees in the city of
Philadelphia--
a lot more data here than you
could actually do in markers,
for example.
So the way they're doing this is
they're actually generating
images on their server,
providing these images to the
application.
The Android API is actually
rendering them
on top of the map.
The really nice thing about
this, as well, is that, via
the API, these tiles and these
images actually rotate and
tilt, like you would expect
them with the map.
The way this works is what Josh
is going to explain now.
JOSH LIVNI: All right,
thanks, Paul.
Yeah, so I'm just going to go
through three simple Chrome
tabs to cover the general
technique they used here.
Let me go ahead and zoom
in this blog post.
So in addition to releasing this
app recently, they also
wrote some notes up on
how they did it.
The title, "WMS On Android," is
kind of what we're going to
walk through for the rest
of the session.
But first, as many of you know,
our base map tiles and
many tiles that you see on maps
come in these 256-pixel
squares that people send over.
They align really nicely.
And you often see them, perhaps,
pre-rendered or
available in some sort of
URL and then an XYZ--
the x-axis, y-axis, and zoom
level of the tiles.
But another way to send images
or rasters like this over the
wire is using something called
WMS, or Web Map Service, a
standard supported by lots of
large organizations, open
source software, and what
they're using here.
PAUL SAXMAN: They support it,
and they provide this data, as
well, right?
A lot of these companies--
or organizations, actually--
provide raster services.
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah, absolutely.
So you can use some open source
software or software of
your choice to create a kind of
WMS service with your data.
Or just go out on the web, which
we'll talk about in a
little bit, and see that there's
lots of public data
available for you
in this format.
So how does one get it into your
Android tile provider?
So this blog post kind
of walks you through.
I'm not going to go into
it in great detail.
You can read it for yourself
on the Azavea blog.
But let's go ahead and take a
look at what is this WMS when
you encounter it in the wild.
So here's an example of the
National Atlas, which has tons
and tons of data layers
available to you on US
government created data sets,
of which there's a lot.
So here are some examples of
some WMS services that we have
available to us.
I'm going to go ahead and
click on one here, this
Agriculture, for example.
And you'll notice the URL here
has GetCapabilities.
A WMS server has two general
requests that you make here--
the GetCapabilities, which tells
you what you can get out
of it, and the GetMap, which, as
you might guess, gives you
back a map image.
So I'll hit the GetCapabilities.
And if I scroll down here,
it's an XML document that
describes all of the features
and different things you can
do with this particular
WMS service.
And they all differ.
The important thing to look for
that we're going to need
to put into our application is
the name of the layer that
we're interested in getting.
So here, they have some layers--
for example, crop 1.
And the other thing that's
really important-- although
there's a few--
are the supported projections.
So the projection that we use in
Google Maps is a Spherical
Mercator projection.
And it goes by, confusingly, a
number of different coordinate
reference systems or spatial
reference systems.
So the sort of official one,
3857 here, if you see that,
you're good to go.
But you could also go ahead
and use any of these--
54004; this ESRI one, 1002113;
or this more common but
unofficial 900913--
Google, in elite speak--
reference system.
And if the WMS says, I support
this, then you're good to go
to overlay the images.
If, for example, it only has
this kind of plate carree 4326
reference system, you're not
going to be able to align the
tiles with a Spherical
Mercator map.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah, different
projection.
And so that's actually a really
interesting thing.
So digging around some of these
WMS providers, I saw
probably about a little over
half actually support the ones
that we can use.
So very important to look for
this when you're looking at
these public WMS servers.
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah.
PAUL SAXMAN: But there are a
number of them out there.
I mean, they're not
hard to find.
JOSH LIVNI: And on that note,
projections are confusing.
So if you want to see us give
a talk on projections--
not going to cover them anymore
today-- let us know in
the comments, and maybe we'll
whip something up.
So the next step is the
GetMap request.
You can see in the URL, there's
a whole bunch of
different parameters.
Here I have my layers
is value 3.
I picked some layer at random.
I have a bounding box,
which I can change.
And I get back this map image.
If I hit back one, my layers
is now crop 1.
I could change it to crop 2.
And I get back images for their
various different layers
that they support in the
bounding box width and height
that are requested.
So the final step is, now that
we know what WMS is, how do we
turn this into the nice
256 tiles and get
them in the tile provider?
And fortunately, again-- thanks,
Azavea; super cool--
you guys produced some open
source code, which Paul has
generalized in some ways and
made really easy for you guys
to get arbitrary
WMS servers in.
So why don't you tell
us about that?
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah.
So this is the
maps-wms-tiles-sample.
We'll link to this in
the description, or
it is linked to.
So basically, I just
forked their code.
Their code is actually
relatively easy to use.
They just have their tile
provider hardcoded in.
I generalized it by pulling it
out into an object that we can
use to populate any number of
different tile providers.
But if you just have your own
tile provider, you want to use
that, definitely you can go
straight to their code and
fork their repository.
So what I did-- if we
go to the next--
so here, you could see in
this code, is I have
five different providers.
These are different tile
providers that are available.
You could see that I generalized
it, so you can
just pass the parameters
that you need.
You definitely need the URL.
You definitely need
the layers.
There's a number of other
optional parameters, things
like the style.
Some of these providers
have different styles.
That's all in the
GetCapabilities.
And then also, there's
transparency.
So by default, if the tile
provider can provide pings
with transparency, then that's
just default on.
But you can turn that off
and actually have an
opaque map if you want.
So this is an example.
So I'm going to run this
application here, so we can
see what it looks like.
So here we are on the
tablet again.
So this is from Google Maps.
JOSH LIVNI: Is this
city lights?
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah, this
is city lights.
JOSH LIVNI: --at night.
Yeah, the NASA city lights that
we've brought into Google
Maps Engine.
And Google Maps Engine also has
a WMS endpoint, amongst
others, that you can get you
data out in KML, integrated
into the Maps API, or a WMS
that then we can use
arbitrarily in applications
such as this.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yep.
So you load your raster data
into Maps Engine, then you
automatically get this
WMS service.
So here, you can see this is
Earth lights at night.
Really nice thing.
So again, you can see these
tiles actually loading as I'm
zooming in.
These are actually coming
from some of
the Maps Engine servers.
And again, you can also
rotate and tilt.
Another example.
So we saw the National
Atlas earlier.
So this is precipitation.
I just switched the map type.
I think this is the
hybrid map.
And you can see this
overlay data.
This is precipitation in
the United States.
And the nice thing about this,
or interesting thing about
this, is you can see that the
labels are actually rendered
on top of the data.
So that's kind of the
default mode.
We don't yet support actually
rendering the labels
underneath the tile overlay.
But--
JOSH LIVNI: Who wants
labels underneath?
That's no good.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah.
Actually, it's the other way
around a lot of times.
Everybody is begging
for people to have
the labels on top.
So this is a nice demonstration
of seeing the
labels and the data.
And again, as we zoom in, as
we're rendering these tiles,
we're just making requests
of the WMS service and
filling them in.
They load a little bit slower
than the map tiles.
Just depends on the speed of
the WMS service that we're
pulling from.
Some other examples
is the NOAA.
So NOAA has a number of
different services.
This one was Watch and Warning,
weather watches and warnings.
So this data looks really great
on top a map, especially
a street map.
And another one from NOAA,
this is Radar.
So radar, you could see a lot
of precipitation out East.
So all this information is
pretty much freely available
to put on top of your map, as
long as you know where the
data comes from and also have
the ability to put it on your
map using the Maps API and
this API from Az--
JOSH LIVNI: Azavea.
PAUL SAXMAN: Azavea.
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah.
Actually, I don't know how
to pronounce it, either.
PAUL SAXMAN: One quick last one,
a really interesting one.
So this one was from USGS.
You can see all counties
in the United States.
So if you wanted to render
this as polygons, you can
imagine that's actually a lot
of work, actually producing
the polygons and actually
rendering them.
This way, rendering them as
raster tiles, it just works.
And easy cheesy.
JOSH LIVNI: Less bandwidth,
yeah.
So it's a best practice, before
you just go hit up a
WMS endpoint, to see if the
provider also has a tile
endpoint, where they've
potentially pre-rendered or
cast or otherwise made available
the kind of XYZ
format tiles.
Since WMS is a lot more
flexible, you're not
unnecessarily using their
CPU to create that.
So check out also, of course,
their usage policy and so
forth before you start grabbing
kind of tiles.
And many of them have
attribution
that they might request.
So just common best practices
when using
anybody's web service.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah, I'm sure
some of these big
guys can handle it.
But if it's somebody that just
put some tiles up for a sample
application and--
JOSH LIVNI: They might be sad.
PAUL SAXMAN: --yeah-- and your
app takes off, then yeah.
JOSH LIVNI: And in a case like
that, where you see something
like that and you have the
rights to use the tiles, but
you're you concerned about
hitting them, you can put up
really simple proxies in
between, like TileCache, which
will sit in between a WMS server
and then spit out these
XYZ tiles, which makes it really
easy on everybody.
But in any case, you can hit it
directly without a proxy or
setting up your own service
using this code here.
And it looks like, really, the
only thing you need to modify
with the code is this
mainactivity.java.
Change the URLs in here to match
what you need, and you
have a working WMS
Android app.
PAUL SAXMAN: Yeah, so either
grab this app, or if you just
have one endpoint.
If you want to play around with
multiple endpoints, use
the code I put up.
If you want to just use one
endpoint and hardcode the URL
in, check out what Azavea
put together.
And there's a lot of--
this is getting up and
running quickly.
You could probably get this app
running in about five, ten
minutes if you know you have to
pace in your key and link
to the Android library.
But beyond all that, it's
actually just pretty
much plug and play.
A lot of advanced topics
around WMS.
There's a number of other WMS
services out there that we
could talk about.
Josh mentioned we could probably
have a whole talk
about projections and
how these work.
If you guys want to hear more
about any of these things,
definitely leave us
some comments.
If you have any questions--
JOSH LIVNI: We love comments
and questions.
PAUL SAXMAN: Absolutely.
So we will try our best
to get back to you
on any of the comments.
And if you just want to tell
us if and how, or not, you
like the show, do
that, as well.
And thanks for joining us.
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah, thanks
for tuning in, guys.
See you in a couple weeks.
PAUL SAXMAN: Adios.